What was today's topic?
I forgot.
Oh,
right.
Hebrew.
No.
Uh,
Arabic.
Hm.
Oh,
right.
I've heard of that one.
What was it?
Uh,
American.
Okay.
Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange Focus Channel and
my name is Paul.
Today's topic is the m horic language or
Ahmadinia as it's known in Amharic.
I'm Horak is one of the major languages
of Ethiopia and it's the official
working language of the Ethiopian
federal government.
Regional and local authorities are free
to choose their working language in
Ethiopia,
but I'm horic is the working language of
several regions.
According to the 2007 census,
it's the native language of 22 million
people or around 30% of the population
of 74 million.
But over the last 10 years,
the population of Ethiopia is thought to
have surpassed 100 million.
And the number of native Amharic
speakers is probably over 30 million.
But Ethiopia is a country where many
people are multilingual and millions.
More people speak Amharic as a second
language,
especially in cities and towns.
Am horic is a member of the Semitic
language family,
which also includes Hebrew,
Arabic,
Aramaic,
and the t gray and too granule languages
which are spoken in Ethiopia and Eritrea
all Semitic languages developed from the
theoretic Prodo Semitic language.
The ethiopic or ECO Semitic languages
are part of the South Semitic branch and
the most common theory is that all Ethio
Semitic languages including I'm
horrific,
developed from a common Prato Ethio
Semitic language.
This Prato Ethio Semitic language is
thought to have developed from the
language of migrants from Southern
Arabia,
presumably old south Arabian languages.
These migrants intermixed with the
native people who spoke who schick
languages and Prodo Ethio Semitic arose.
This language was a direct descendant of
the language of the migrants from this
protal Ethio Semitic language.
Two branches developed the southern
branch,
which includes I'm horic and the
northern branch,
which includes t gray to [inaudible] and
gaze,
the oldest attested Ethio Semitic
language and the one that became the
official language of the [inaudible]
empire and remained the official
literary language in Ethiopia until the
19th century.
Some believe in that theory of migration
from Southern Arabia.
But some believe that I'm horic
developed from a Semitic language that
had existed in the area before that
migration.
And in recent years,
another theory has arisen that I'm horic
is actually a creole that arose from
contact between Semitic speaking
officers and cush should expediating
soldiers in the accent might empire
after the fourth century.
But this theory is hotly contested and
is not the general consensus.
The earliest known am Horak writing is
from the 13th century,
even though it was mainly a spoken
language at that time.
This was the time of the solomonic
dynasty when King,
no,
I'm luck,
made Amharic,
the spoken Lingua Franca of the
Ethiopian courts,
and it became known as the language of
the king to sign a new goose gaze.
The language of the previous x amount
rulers continued to be used as the
language of literature.
The sonance oof.
This resulted in a diagnostic situation
that would last for centuries with gays
being used from literature and did the
Ethiopian Orthodox Church.
And I'm Horak being used in speech in
the 15th century under the rule of Zadie
Yacob troops who collected taxes for the
king likely brought em horic into other
regions.
Further south in the mid 19th century am
Horak began to replace a gaze as the
literary language case in point,
the Ethiopian Emperor's tail,
just the second and mindy leak.
The second had their chronicles written
in Amharic rather than gaze,
which had been used for previous
emperors under mini leak.
The second Ethiopia grew into something
resembling its current borders am Horak
became the defacto official language and
emhart speaking officials were
responsible for the newly incorporated
territories.
The spread of the printing press in the
19th and 20th centuries contributed
further to the spread of Mri as in the
20th century.
Most new print materials including the
first newspaper,
were written in an pauric rather than
gays.
In the early 20th century,
Italian,
French and English were used as the main
languages of school instruction.
But then in 19:44
AM horic became the sole language of
instruction in primary schools under the
rule of Haile Selassie.
He then made them Horak the official
language of Ethiopia in 1955 during the
socialist government known as the deck
from 1974 to 1991 increased development,
urbanization and an increase in the
number of public schools and adult
literacy programs caused them horic to
spread even more,
but still empiric was much more widely
spoken in towns and cities and not as
widely spoken in rural areas except in
its original native regions.
After 1991 language policies were
changed to give more influenced to the
other languages of Ethiopia and there
are over 80 of them currently regional
and local authorities can choose their
own working language and their own
language of primary school education.
But Amharic remains the most widely
spoken Lingua Franca with a large
proportion of the urban population
throughout the country being able to
speak Amharic.
So what does,
I'm Horak like first of all,
what's this interesting script that I'm
Horak is written in?
Well that's actually the gay script,
which is used not only to write the gays
language,
but also amharic to Grenada and others.
The gay script is an Abogada.
Each character represents a syllable and
consists of a consonant as its major
components plus an attached ligature or
other modification that represents a
vowel in Amharic.
This gaze based writing system is called
[inaudible] and I'm Horak.
There are plain consonants similar to
most of the consonants in English,
and there are glottals sized consonants
or ejective consonants.
Globalized consonants are produced by
closing and reopening the gladys the
space between your vocal chords while
making the consonant sound.
When transliterated using Latin
characters,
they usually have a dot underneath them
to distinguish them from their non
globalized equivalents.
Let's compare a plane consonant with
it's globalized equivalent to Teta.
Also notice the doubled consonant.
All consonants can be short or long,
long meaning that the consonant is
doubled double in length.
The distinction between short and long
consonants is important because
sometimes the meaning of words is
distinguished by the length of the
continent.
For example,
this means he said this means there is,
this means swimming one,
Nah,
this means important,
so in both cases,
the length of the consonant
distinguishes the meaning of the words
doubled.
Consonants are not distinguished in
writing,
but in context amharic speakers have
little trouble with that sentence
structure.
First,
let's look at an equational sentence
using the verb to be you jus a Gel.
No,
this means the boy is short word for
word,
it's boy.
The short is Ou is a definite article is
boy you is the boy.
Notice that the verb to be is at the end
and the adjective comes before it.
Amharic is a verb.
Final language.
So when predicate of sentences,
the word order is sv or Ovi or Sov.
Of course some sentences have no object
just to subject and an intransitive
verb.
For example,
did you?
What the sentence means?
The child fell word for word.
It's child,
Duh.
He fell.
So this is the subject and this is the
verb and here's a sentence that does
have a direct object.
It means that the hunter killed Elian
word for word.
It's hunter,
the lion he killed.
Here's the subject,
the object and the verb.
Something we can add to this sentence is
the optional direct object marker.
Good Delta.
If you use the direct object marker,
then it's also possible to place the
object at the beginning of the sentence,
making it,
oh sv.
Good.
And now let's try adding an adjective to
the sentence I knew to look good.
Dead.
The sentence now means the hunter killed
a big lion and you can see that the
adjective is placed before the noun.
The previous sentences all have an
explicit subject,
but there can also be no explicit
subject.
For example,
this sentence meaning he opened the door
that rune [inaudible] word for word,
it's door direct object marker.
He opened.
No explicit subject is necessary here
because we know from the form of the
verb that it refers to the third person,
masculine,
singular.
He.
So this sentence is just olvey object,
verb.
And that brings us to verbs similar to
an other Semitic languages.
The verb consists of a stem and
suffixes,
which indicate the person,
gender,
and number of the subject.
Let's take a look at this example.
Verb meaning to break.
Here's the stem of the perfect form and
the suffix is placed after the stem.
Tell us about the doer of the action.
Sebesta sub sub,
sub sub sub borough Sabera to sub
Barron.
Now let's look at the imperfect form
based on this stem.
You said Rod to [inaudible] to
[inaudible],
the root system.
Let's take a look at the stems of the
perfect form and the imperfect form
again,
and let's focus on these letters here.
Similar to an other Semitic languages.
I'm Horak uses a system of root letters
and templates into which the root
letters are inserted.
Roots consist of consonants commonly
three,
but it can also be two,
four or five and they are placed into
templates consisting of a vowel pattern
as well as some continental affixes.
The root gives us the core meaning and
the template gives us grammatical
information and more specific
information about the meaning.
Notice that with this verb,
the second route letter is doubled or
germinated in the perfect form.
This is true for some verbs but not for
others.
Those are a few of the important
features of them.
Horic.
Let's look at a few more example
sentences and see what else we find.
Here's the sentence,
meaning we must go today.
Study.
Made a Leben word for word.
It's today to go.
We must,
in this sentence,
we see a modal verb meaning must just
like other verbs.
This modal verb is conjugated for the
subject.
In this case,
we,
the modal verb comes at the end and
before that we see the main verb meaning
to go in.
It's infinitive form another sentence.
How can you meet [inaudible]?
This means where can I find a doctor?
[inaudible] word for word,
it's doctor.
Where is found?
The word Hakeem is the same as the
Arabic word for doctor and I would guess
that this is a lone word.
This word means where question words
usually come directly before the verb
and you can see that the object of the
verb comes first.
This is an imperfect verb with these
root consonants.
The ethics is showed that this is the
third person singular forum.
And onto the next sentence,
you're making a good of still being at
this means I've lost my car keys work
for words of car.
My key have been lost to me.
This pattern here of plus a noun plus
another.
Now is a typical way of showing
possession or connection between two
nouns,
and this is a verb with these two root
consonants,
which mean to lose,
but this particular verb template makes
it reflexive or intransitive.
So what means to be lost?
This is the conjunct form of the which
can be used like the present perfect in
English and this ending here,
I mean something like happened to me
showing that the speaker is affected by
the action.
Notice that in this sentence,
the word for key is singular.
Plural can often be understood from the
context even if you're used the singular
form,
but we can also use an explicit plural
form of Tau Vignette.
Again,
this means I've lost my car keys,
but here you can see that a plural
ending has been added to the word for
key,
but it's not entirely necessary to use
the plural form.
You can use the singular form and it
context.
It should be clear whether you're
talking about just one or many and onto
the next sentence and Magoo and no
deadline.
This means we love Ethiopian cuisine.
Word for word,
it's of Ethiopia food we love.
Again,
we see that pattern showing possession
or relationship between two nouns and
here we see the imperfect form of the
verb,
meaning to love.
Here's the stem and she wrote the
affixes telling us that this is first
person plural.
In other words,
the we form and one more sentence that
it took going,
that's a better outcome.
This means I didn't break the vase that
it going.
That's a better word for word.
It's veys.
I broke negative conjugation in Amharic,
there's a special negative perfect form
of verbs.
The negative form is made by adding this
prefix and the suffix to the regular
perfect for them.
And here's the word for veys and here
are the definite article suffix,
but since it's following another vowel,
it's written as well rather than Ooh as
a Semitic language,
amharic has some vocabulary that
overlaps with other Semitic languages
like Hebrew and Arabic.
Some of the similar words are loan words
from other languages like Arabic or
gays,
but some are cognates that develop from
a common ancestor as the words and other
Semitic languages.
And sometimes it's hard to know if the
word is a lone word or an original
cognate.
For example,
the word we saw before,
which means break the same.
The third person,
perfect form and Hebrew would be Shavaya
and in Hebrew sometimes the second route
letter like a v sound is doubled and
pronounced like a b sound,
which makes the similarity even more
obvious.
And we also solve the work to kill.
This is the third person.
Perfect form.
In Hebrew,
it's cattal meaning to slay or to kill.
In Arabic,
it's clicky law.
The consonants here are not exactly the
same,
but I think there's a connection between
the g sound in Amharic and the cup or
sounds in the other languages.
And I think there's a connection between
the de and the sounds in the other
languages.
Another example,
the word for Berry in Hebrew,
it's havas and an Arabic of butter in
Amharic.
The verb meaning to here is sem,
and this is the third person.
Perfect form,
meaning he heard in Hebrew,
it's Shama in Arabic,
it's some off in Hebrew and Arabic.
There's an extra route letter that was
lost in the [inaudible] word and it has
mostly become silent and modern Hebrew
but still written and I'm horic.
The word for I is in Hebrew it's iron
and in Arabic gets,
I mean I would love to be able to say
that the English word I is related to
those but it's not another one.
In Amharic there's theirs which means
house.
In Hebrew it's bite,
but when it's used in a compound word
with another noun,
it's pronounced the bait like in
Batesville,
the word force school in Arabic it's
bait or bite,
but the amount of vocabulary that M
Horak has in common with Hebrew and
Arabic might be less than you'd expect.
That's partly because a lot of the
vocabulary is of Ku shidduch origin as
much as 30% and other vocabulary is
unique to empiric or to Ethio.
Semitic.
Amharic is a very interesting language
and it's a language with clearly semitic
features including the verbal system and
the root system using continental roots
and inserting them into templates.
Those are things I'm familiar with from
other Semitic languages like Hebrew and
Arabic and then include some of the
vocabulary we just looked at a second
ago,
but some elements are quite different
from other Semitic languages such as its
Sov word order.
Amharic is a language that I would love
to dig into more in the future.
At some point in my last video on
Japanese,
I forgot to ask a question of the day.
So today I'm not going to forget.
Here is the question of the day for
speakers of M Horak.
How widely is amharic spoken in your
area and your community and if you're an
immigrant from Ethiopia living somewhere
else in the world,
what language do members of your
community normally speak with each other
and for speakers of other Semitic
languages?
Have you noticed the similarities
between m horic and your language?
What sorts of similarities have you
noticed?
Be sure to follow Lang,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
And once again I want to say thank you
to all of my patrion supporters,
especially these wonderful people right
here on the screen for their monthly
pledges.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.
Yeah.